[Music]
thank you very much for joining us today
you just released your book feminism for
women challenging the direction that
modern feminism is taking would you mind
telling us a bit about the book and what
inspired you to write it
i've wanted to write this book for a
long time because
i
encounter constantly younger generations
of feminists so i'm 59 so there might be
a whole two generations younger than me
saying that for them things are really
difficult right now
because of the proliferation of really
extreme sadistic pornography that seems
to be just
normalized amongst young men even boys
and the effect that that has on them
but also the way that
young feminists
are trying to challenge orthodoxies
such as for example the notion that sex
work is work
when it is understood by feminists
globally who campaign against male
violence as abuse and exploitation of
the most disenfranchised women so
indigenous women poor women women of
color black women
all of those that are targeted
disproportionately
compared to other populations
to be abused by men
so they are being told by often by male
leaders self-proclaimed leaders
of feminist societies of lgbt groups
in university settings and elsewhere on
social media and in real life
that they are wrong that they are prudes
that they are anti-sex
that they need to lighten up
that in fact sex work is liberating
empowering a woman's choice
and it was after encountering
women telling me these things
for a number of years
that i decided to write a book that
might be helpful for them
whether they agree with it or not is
really beside the point but it might
help them understand
how we got to a situation
where what passes for feminism today
seems to benefit men more than it does
women so how do you describe the
difference between liberation feminism
and equality feminism and what societal
movements triggered the shift from one
to the other do you think the feminism
that i became involved in at the very
end of the 1970s when i was still in my
teens i was 17 years old
was
anti-male violence campaigning
so i met with feminists that were older
than me
in leeds a city in the north of england
where there was a big manhunt
for a serial killer called peter
sutcliffe
who
had killed women sadistically brutally
um
killed several women who the police had
decided were involved in prostitution so
therefore they didn't matter as much as
other women um and it was this bungled
police
operation
where women were told to stay at home at
night
but men were not
and whether
the press the national and local press
reflected that attitude of women
not really mattering if they'd been
prostituted or if they were somehow
behaving as women should not in other
words they were out drinking in pubs
they were on their own
that led me to
prioritizing this issue
because what i came to understand
was that women can never be liberated if
we are fearing and experiencing male
violence from flashing to sexual
harassment in the workplace or on street
through to rape and sexual assault and
femicide
the killing of women because we're women
and so that to me became much more
important
than what i call glass ceiling feminism
the kind of equality feminism that you
would see
in
some states in the us
in scandinavia
so take for example sweden norway
iceland those countries have really good
records when it comes to
equal pay pension rights maternity leave
maternity benefits child care et cetera
for women but the levels of rape
domestic violence and femicide are as
high
in countries where there is less social
and legal equality so what does that
mean and also in terms of political
representation
equality feminism would have us think
that
50 female members of parliament
will cancel out sexism
just imagine the chamber in the house of
commons
you've got 50 women and 50 men which
ones are going to speak the most
and the loudest and feel the most
entitled who's going to be heard more so
that's not going to work
you know give me 70 80 female mps we
might be talking
but then what about the violence and the
curtailment
of the lives of women in politics or
in
jobs
with zero hour contracts
it's the same in many ways if they're
experiencing coercive control sexual and
domestic violence
and their trauma is being
dismissed and they're being told that
they are to blame for what's happened to
them
so liberation feminism is to seek to end
all male violence
to see patriarchy and male dominance
as
the kind of deciding factor
in whether or not women can break out of
sexist
societies
and to recognize women as a sex class
and men as a sex class
and therefore in order to end male
violence and liberate women you have to
end male violence because it is the tool
that is used to keep women in our place
even though of course not all men
not all men commit acts of rape not all
men kill enough do
for it not to be necessary
to have a gun held at the head of every
woman it curtails our lives
so is it almost as if kind of liberation
feminism is what has to come first and
after that an equality feminism will
sort itself out almost well you know
equality feminism only benefits certain
women
who
have particular jobs
who are
not as poorly served as other women
so middle class upper middle class women
women from elite societies who are still
oppressed by sexism by patriarchy
still are targets for male violence
still are dismissed when they report
rape and sexual assault
but
seem to focus more
on things that will benefit them in
their middle class lives now they still
need feminism feminism is for every
woman not every woman is a feminist
obviously
but
equality
will not be an issue
after liberation because if we're
liberated from patriarchy
why would women be seen as lesser than
men
why would women
be
seen as undeserving disbelieved
we wouldn't be the target of
discrimination in that way
because there would be no need for that
constant reinforcement
of male
supremacy of male entitlement
so what role should men have in the
movement for a woman's liberation
there's a really crucial role for men
which is to
not just be a bystander
and to support feminism in our causes
and to do that it's not about wearing a
t-shirt saying hey i'm a great feminist
in fact i'm a better feminist than you
it's not asking for
a seat at the table
or
a speaking slot at a conference
to talk about the wonderful work that
you might be doing that men might be
doing
to end male violence it's actually about
recognizing
that it is inhumane
to abuse women it's inhumane to consume
the kind of pornography
where women are being tortured women are
being harmed women are being hurt women
are screaming begging
for her abuser to stop and for men to
get sexually excited by that that can
only happen with the dehumanization of
women
so the role of men is to say to other
men don't do it it's not cool
and let's talk about why
we have bought this line
that we are
going to be educated in
sex and relationships
through watching women being tortured
on set why have we been told that if we
fancy a bit of sex but it's not the kind
of sex that my girlfriend gives me or i
don't have a girlfriend
because i'm a bit of a jerk and i can't
get a real date that it's fine to go
into a brothel and pay for sexual access
to a woman who does not want you
and she's not consenting or the cash
wouldn't be involved to ask those very
difficult questions of other men
about making jokes about hitting women
about making jokes about ugly birds on
the night out
and constantly challenge
sexism
and talk to women
and hear about the experiences of women
when they're out at night in a taxi on
the way home after being drinking
or relaxing on holiday
and compare them to your own
because men don't have to go out
clutching their keys between their
fingers
some men are clearly targets
black men gay men you know of course
there can be targets of violence from
other men but not simply because they're
born male
with the new legislations around
abortion taking place in texas many
human rights organizations decide to use
the wording people who can get pregnant
rather than simply women to describe the
ones being affected by the new law would
you consider this a step towards
inclusivity or an act of erasure of
women it's not inclusive if you're
excluding
half of the planet
and i'd be perfectly happy never to use
gendered language again i've got no idea
what it feels like to be a woman
we don't know
there's nothing innate about it
it's only in relation to the way we're
treated by men and often our biology is
used as part of that
part of that punishment
so we're not oppressed because we have
biology
that is used to justify it
it's absolutely ridiculous to suggest
that before
women are liberated from patriarchy and
before we see an end to male violence
and male supremacy so we can pretend
that we're all people on an equal
playing field
so it's a pertinent question about the
abortion
issue
men do not need ever to access abortion
ever
and if trans men do that's because they
have female biology and that is a simple
biological fact that matters when we
look at
issues of health care
other medical issues
but what's really important is the
documentation
of
sex crimes
who's committing them and who against
whom
you have a situation as we currently do
with more than 20 police forces
choosing
to
log
a crime
that has been alleged against a man
where they choose to override
that person's sex biological sex with
gender identity what does that even mean
because rape is a sexed crime
only people with a penis can commit it
that's enshrined in our legislation
all of a sudden we're seeing reports in
newspapers and even ons reports
government statistics
that are skewing
the facts
where apparently all of a sudden
women are downloading
violent
child abuse imagery
women have been
arrested for rape
women have been arrested on child abuse
charges when in fact these are
biological males following the pattern
of male
behavior male behavior under patriarchy
not because it's innate
and women are not committing these
crimes
so that's why i think that until
the great revolution
we have to be very clear
about biological sex and we have to
record it as such people can define
however they want they can use whatever
pronouns
they can use whatever identity they wish
but we cannot pretend
in some orwellian twist
that
women
are raping when it's biological men and
in a dream scenario where do you see the
future of feminism heading and you know
similarly what do you fear well
feminism is the most optimistic movement
on the planet
we have to be
because we want to see change and we
work towards change the whole time
but also we don't believe that boys are
born
programmed to rape and to harm women and
we don't believe girls are born victims
so we recognize it's socialization
and it's the cultural context in which
boys grow
that give some permission
to act upon abusive fantasies and
scenarios
because it upholds power
so feminism
has a very bright future
because since
the beginning of the second wave of
feminism as it's known i just call it
feminism
more and more men have become educated
about their role
as human beings
that they cannot use the excuse that
they can't help themselves
that somehow they'll have to go out and
rape and kill women if they get sexually
frustrated or if they're disrespected in
some way
it's now understood even though some men
refuse to accept it
that none of this is innate or
programmed
and i see progress all over the world i
see legal and social and political
changes that have been brought about by
active feminists
what i fear is that young women will
become so silenced that they won't dare
practice real feminism
for fear of being censored silenced
punished
but
the more of us that can stand in front
of them
mentor and support them take the bullet
for them if need be
the more strength that they'll get
as
confident feminists and will move
forward in a very positive way
and why is government regulation
around you know
sites that clearly
put forward harmful ideas such as
pornography why is the the regulation so
lax
regulation on pornography in the sex
trade in general is lacks because it's
about profit
pornographers get very excited by profit
much more than they do about sex
and so
why would you regulate a hugely
profitable industry
it's as simple as that but the second
strand to this is that the victims are
women and girls primarily not all but
primarily
and we matter less than do men which is
why we've got feminism
you've written some really interesting
articles on um you know for example
umoja in
kenya a village where men are banned um
how have these experiences impacted your
personal feminist ideology and in
particular the value of women's only
spaces
i first met i was introduced to women
only spaces
as a very young feminist and as a young
lesbian that was really crucial because
of course i was under threat for being
in that lesbian
it was much harder than it is now but
it's not ideal now
so women only spaces were very important
to be able to talk to other women about
the danger of rejecting men and about
what we saw for ourselves for the future
doing something quite brave and quiet
out there
going to places like emoji
and seeing how women
who have
way less than we do in the west way less
in terms of resources
legislation to support them
really inspired me because every trip i
make where i go to
visit women who are resisting male
violence
but with the most resistance from their
governments and from men
makes me feel like i want to fight
harder
because if they can do it then so can we
but what it also does is it forges
solidarity between women across the
globe which is one of the most wonderful
things about the internet because now we
can meet each other without physically
doing the travelling
so doing the travelling is the best
thing ever
because i get to meet with them and i
get to learn so much from them and i get
to report on it
and my world has expanded
through that
and i feel extremely lucky to be able to
do it
julie bindu thank you very much
for more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today to the institute of art
and ideas at iai tv
you